yo what is up everybody methyl you here
and today i'm going to be showing you
guys a cool contest that nvidia posted
out that is giving away free fall out
for words and free other fall out
merchandise I'm just putting this video
guys out to show you this contest exists
I'll put a link in it in the video in
the description probably comment about
it too so it's the fall out for
radiation check contest by sponsored by
Nvidia I'm not paid to do this I just
thought you guys might want to know
about this so it's share your best
radiation check pictures for chances to
win Nvidia and follow up for prizes now
these prizes if you go down here you can
see that there's a grand prize runner
ups and more runner-ups grand prize
prize is a ton of stuff it is a fully
modded pc for fallout from nvidia poster
signed by the dev team the fall for a
fallout 4 pitboy edition of gtx 970
fallout 4 style just a ton of stuff and
then even the second place runner ups
which i don't know how many there are
but maybe multiple you get a fought for
Pip Boy edition and the GP the gtx 970
which is a really good graphics card i
think it's good to grab it start of
music and then 250 runner-ups get a
fallout 4 a vault boy mask but it's kind
of pretty cool like that's kind of cool
so now this you're probably wondering
how you get in in this contest it's
pretty simple you just go to the contest
go to hear go on twitter i think you
need to Twitter you tweet out your best
picture of the fallout 4 or not follow
for fallout radiation check which is
when the fall boy put the vault boy puts
his thumb up to check if there's a if
he's going to die from radiation from
the nuke and you can see that there's a
bunch of people these couple ones I
don't think they're super great but they
were posted on the first day this is
like the third day the contest has been
out I think and these were posted on the
first day and so they just got a bunch
of likes from being first and also this
is just copy of this one so i don't know
i don't what the heck that's about so
you just scroll down you can see there's
a lot mine i actually posted my own is
actually right here prestige mad luigi
that's my twitter and so you post the
thing onto twitter you can see over here
I
posted this on twitter with the hat the
nvidia geforce f fallout hashtag
radiation and i'm doing the little
reluctant guy giving the thumbs because
kind of man stuff I've have a pretty
good picture i put made this picture
pretty quickly just a mix of the normal
vault boy and the little angry modded
vault boy and so if you guys wanna you
know on go click that like button then I
appreciate it very much but yeah you can
just go and whichever ones you think are
cool like I think I saw want to up here
I don't know where went but say I think
let's see which one do i think is cool I
think this yet is one I think that's
cool so I just click the little like
button I don't need to be signed in at
all and then it's good and then I'd that
counted as a boat and i'm not sure if
you have to but I think you have to you
enter now you put all your details in
and then also you do the thing on
Twitter I just fill this out and then
upload my image and then also did it on
Twitter and then it worked out well for
me so it's gotta be the whole this is
the video i just want to show you guys
that this exists since there's not like
crazy amount of people go into this
there have been more people in the past
couple days but um there isn't a ton
there's like like a crazy amount of
pictures i can actually find the end of
this pretty quickly you see this has
crazy mess of likes alright but
everybody i hope you enjoy the video and
yeah keep looking at my channel for more
fallout stuff fall for that's coming out
soon and that's going to be pretty cool
hope you guys enjoyed this peace out